so it is not easy and it's a bit of a
risk to jump into a franchise that has a
huge fan base a ton of expectations but
between this movie and spider-verse I
feel like you have the secret so how do
you guys what was it about those two
movies that you knew made them something
special thank you
well I guess a number of things that
people involved the story itself you
know Spider versus is I mean that was
kind of something I've been doing on the
road for the last couple of years and
seeing that for the first time was very
much like my experience in seeing this
for the first time where it's kind of
just like you're moving and you're going
and all this stuff's happening around
you or in this case all this stuff is
not happening around you and then you go
and see it and it's just this
unbelievable outcome but to be a part of
something to things in this sense that
have such an incredible fan base built
in and and means so much to so many
people is really an honor I have a
feeling this one's gonna mean something
to a lot of people out there to
something I am a little obsessed with
watching b-roll i watch a lot of b-roll
okay too much and this b-roll is some of
the best because you just seem so into
it you're talking to the camera you're
talking about the locations I think I
caught a shot of you and Travis riding
one at the roller coaster park is this
as fun as it looks were you really just
soaking in every second of this movie I
really had a blast making this film we
shot it in all around California I'm
born and raised here and haven't been to
I mean more than half the places we shot
and I questioned why I had never been
there before but they just got to travel
to some of the most beautiful places and
amazing people and working with Travis
was incredible because here's a guy who
is just like beyond brilliant but just
beyond passionate about this story and
and where it came from and he's got such
a connection to it himself as a child of
the 80s so yeah it really just overall
was a was a experience I'll never forget
it all comes through the screen big time
can you tell me a little bit about
shooting some of your conversation
scenes with bumblebee especially because
of the timing because it's not like
bumblebee talks back to you right and if
someone talking to you so if someone
cueing you interest
no I that was that was one of the
moments for I at one point questioned my
well-being and insanity level because I
thought that it wasn't gonna end well
because I was talking to myself the
whole time taking my own timing hoping
and praying that it was right
and luckily again Travis was right there
to check in with me and make sure I was
cool but yeah it was all my own timing
which was you know a weird thing and
obviously a lot can be done in post when
it came to that but it was a weird thing
to be able to because at first I was
like maybe maybe it would be nice to
just have a person there to at least
give me some sort of nonverbal reaction
and I actually had that at one point it
was just a little too weird to like have
somebody not talk to you so I guess you
know in in a sense this character is
talking to you know what feels like an
imaginary friend but is there so I guess
creating the parallels in what could
have been real for me in my life - what
is going on in hers was really what came
what it came down to and now walking
away from it do you have any abilities
whatsoever when it comes to fixing cars
hmm yeah see it's kind of like when you
study for a test and then you ace the
test then you forget everything the next
day is yeah yeah that's kind of where
I'm at
you